good afternoon everyone and welcome to
our session at the festival of Dangerous
Ideas we are the gods now I'm Ann Mossop
from the Sydney Opera House I'm one of
the curators of the festival of
Dangerous Ideas and it's a great
pleasure to welcome you here this
afternoon to hear from Jason Silva when
we were planning the festival we really
wanted to talk about the future and the
impact of technology on the future and
because of our experience trying to talk
about scientific topics pessimistic
topics difficult topics we decided we
really needed to find somebody about the
future to could talk about the future of
technology in a way that was optimistic
and exciting and that was going to get
people to think about this these kind of
very complicated and sometimes difficult
issues with a positive undertone to what
they were saying and we were absolutely
very so excited when we came across the
work of Jason Silva and a few weeks
after we talked to Jason and started to
arrange for him to come we found out
that he was speaking at Ted and I was
fortunate to see him speak they're
introducing a video he had made for that
conference and I thought yes this is
something that's going to be really
wonderful to see in the year in the
festival of Dangerous Ideas Jason is
someone who's hard to categorize he's
not someone where I can say oh yes he's
the author of XYZ and he's a professor
here and there jason is a philosopher a
filmmaker a visionary I think someone
who above all is a really extraordinary
communicator about science about
complexity and about the future so I'm
delighted that he's here to talk to us
this afternoon please make sure that
your phones are on silence on silent
tweet to hashtag fodi which has been
hacked because so many of you are
getting so involved in the conversation
that it became a magnet to a lot of
people trying to get you to buy
something else but we're fixing that and
and twitter is still going through so
don't don't hold back Jason is going to
talk to us for about half an hour 30
minutes 40 minutes
and then there'll be plenty of time for
questions and discussion from you
because I think this is something where
you will get a lot of provocative ideas
so the opportunity to have a
conversation with Jason today is going
to be one of the great pleasures of this
session so please join me in welcoming
Jason Silva
Wow
hi everybody how you guys doing
hope you guys are doing great we are the
gods now what a topic huh and I suppose
for me the big inspiration behind this
came after I read Ernest Becker's book
Pulitzer prize-winning book the denial
of death in 1974 pop-culture reference
for that book it's the book that Woody
Allen gives Annie Hall in the movie
Annie Hall and he says look you need to
read this so you can understand where
I'm coming from and basically the denial
of death said that the human condition
is characterized characterized uniquely
by our awareness of our mortality in
other words we're the only species that
is aware that we are mortal beings and
this causes a tremendous amount of
anxiety we would go mad if we hadn't
come up with solutions to the death
problem and throughout history you know
Ernest Becker identifies three main
solutions to the problem of death the
first one was the religious solution to
the problem of death you create a
narrative in which you will your soul
will live forever in the kingdom of God
and it gets rid of the death issue
because everything will be taken care of
in the end now as technology has
increasingly Science and Technology
increasingly made religion sort of more
difficult to believe we've had to come
up with other solutions to the death
problem the second main solution to the
problem of death that Ernest Becker
identifies is the romantic solution you
turn your lovers into deities she's like
the wind she's my salvation it's the
lyric to every pop song she is the Sun
but of course no relationship can
ultimately bear the burden of godhood
eventually your gods reveal their clay
feet and all of a sudden we can't be
saved by our lovers and the anxiety
about our mortal coil kicks in again
Ernest Becker says we are God's with
anuses we have this capacity to ponder
the infinite were seemingly capable of
anything we can mainline the whole of
time through the optic nerve with our
astronomy and with our space telescopes
and yet we're housed in these heart
pumping breath gasping decaying bodies
so to be godly yet creaturely is just
possibly cruel the last solution to the
problem of death that Ernest Becker
identifies he calls the creative
solution I think this is perhaps the
most interesting one for a variety of
reasons of course symbolically the
creative solution allows us to create
great works of art to create work that
will outlive us and that will outlast us
to leave a sort of symbolic immortality
and the legacy of that sort but also the
creative solution to the problem of
death I think is the engineering
solution it's the way through which we
remake the world it's the way in which
we transcend our limitations using
science and technology and this gets me
really excited because this is
ultimately how I see technology
technology is a scaffolding Andy Clark
the cognitive philosophers tech
technology is our second skin Terence
Mckenna says it's the real skin of our
species through technology we transcend
the limitations of thought reach and
vision we extend ourselves we transcend
time space and distance technologies is
our extended phenotype as Dawkins says
it's really what we are our skyscrapers
are jet engines that's us
just like the termite colony is
temperature controlled and it's a part
of the termite species so too technology
is a part of who we are
now as Ann said I'm a filmmaker and my
background is I worked in television I
worked for Al Gore's TV network for a
number of years and I fell in love with
the power of short form filmmaking I
felt that uh with short form you could
create content that could spread that
could be shared in the age of social
media and when I left Current TV I
decided to create a series of short
films micro documentaries that look at
the coevolution of humans and technology
because I fell so in love with this idea
of technology as a means to transcend
our boundaries that I felt like this was
a narrative that needed to be put out
there in the world because we live in
this world of doom and gloom we live in
a media environment where if it bleeds
it leads
there's a reason for that my friend
Peter Diamandis founder of the expertise
in singularity University wrote a book
called abundance why the future will be
much better than you think
and in the book it talks about how we
have these overactive amygdala that
we've inherited from a time
we used to live in the savannahs of
Africa and it was biologically
advantageous for us to be really nervous
all the time and always looking for
danger right because it kept us alive
against the tiger you know so that the
tiger would need us now we've inherited
that but now we live in a world that is
increasingly safer increasingly less
violent I don't know if you guys know
the work of Steven Pinker who says that
the chances of a man dying at the hands
of another man today are the lowest
they've ever been or the work of Matt
Ridley who actually shows the inexorable
progress that we've made using science
and technology and how the world has
actually never been better or the work
of Hans Roblin who has the website
gapminder.org that went viral a couple
of years ago because it showed how every
nation in the world by every measurable
indicator has been rising quality of
life has been rising over the last 200
but we don't notice this because we have
these overactive amygdala that are just
looking for danger in our increasingly
wired world is more than happy to
showcase all the danger even though it's
less than there's ever been before
anyway I promise to go slow so I decided
that there was room there was room to
start a new conversation about how we
see ourselves and how we see technology
and I felt that online video had become
ubiquitous enough that we could actually
create content that was short form that
was infectious and that people could
then spread and so I started to do this
and I created a project a series of
shorts I call them shots of
philosophical espresso and the point of
the content is to pull you out of
context in such a dramatic manner in
order to force you to gawk in amazement
at the ubiquitous everyday wonders that
we seem to be culturally disposed to
ignore okay so what I'd like to do today
is actually want to show you it walk you
through a series of these short films
which will hopefully convince you that
we are on our way to becoming God's the
first film I want to show you is
actually an ode to the power of ideas
and let's play it and then we'll talk a
little bit about the themes you know I
love this idea of radical openness free
exchange of information the free flow of
ideas creating spaces in which ideas can
have
says Matt Ridley talks about and this is
huge because it turns out that ideas are
just as real as the neurons they inhabit
as James Blake tells it you know a new
kingdom rises above the biosphere
denizens of this kingdom are ideas
because ideas have retained some of the
properties of organisms it turns out
they leap from brain to brain that can
beat for the limited resources of our
attention
they have infectivity they have
spreading power they are what Richard
Dawkins calls the new replicators born
from the primordial soup of human
culture their vector of transmission is
language and electronic communication
and though ideas are not made of nucleic
acid they have achieved more
evolutionary change and at a rate leaves
the old gene panting far behind you know
Ray Kurzweil says our ability to create
virtual models in our heads combined
with our oddest-looking thumbs was
sufficient to usher in a secondary force
of evolution in home technology and it
will continue until the entire universe
is at our fingertips this is
unbelievable stuff it speaks to the
telescoping nature evolutionary change
more change in the last 100 years than
in the last billion years Terence
Mckenna actually wrote from the moment
that human beings invented language
biological evolution essentially ceased
and evolution became a cultural
epigenetic phenomenon now we take in
matter of low organization we put it
through our mental filters and we
extrude it in the form of space shuttles
and iPhones
you know the imaginary foundation tells
us that what imagination does is it
allows us to conceive of delightful
future possibilities pick the most
amazing one and pull the present forward
to meet it you know imagine how
impoverished this world would have been
we hadn't invented the technology of the
oil paints and the time for Van Gogh for
the technology of the musical instrument
time for Beethoven Mozart to unfurl
through it to know with the revolutions
biotechnology nanotechnology the free
exchange of information is allowing us
to conceive of radical new things
Freeman Dyson says in the future new
generation of artists will be writing
genomes which was Lewin see the Blake
and Byron Road versus what is great and
man said Nietzsche is that he is a
bridge and not an end you know we're on
a trajectory smack in the middle between
the thorn and the made Road Kevin Kelley
and so radical openness it's huge it's a
universe of possibility it's gray and
fused by color it's the invisible
revealed it's the mundane blown away by
all we need to cultivate radical
openness as a way of participating in
accelerating evolution Wow indeed thank
you is that loud enough yeah you know
people often ask me why video why art
you know at the end of the day I'm not a
technologist I'm not a scientist even
though the message I'm putting out there
is that increasingly a group a small
group of passionate people small group
of passionate technologists can do what
only huge corporations and governments
could do mere decades ago and this is
happening on the back of these
exponentially growing technologies and
I'm going to get into that but I'd like
to share with you a line by Marshall
McLuhan which I think really sums up why
I use short form video to kind of infect
people with awe and he says it's always
been the artist who perceives the
alterations in man caused by a new
medium who recognizes that the future is
the present and who uses his work to
prepare the grounds for it now one of
the things that that video obviously
talks about is the power of ideas to
transform the world you heard me say
that even though ideas even though memes
are not made of nucleic acid they still
have achieved more evolutionary change
more change than that biological
evolution ever did and in order to
understand this you have to happen you
have to understand that this change is
happening on the back of these
exponentially emerging technologies now
exponential growth is counterintuitive
to the way our brains perceive the world
our brains evolved in a world that was
linear and local but we now live in a
world that is global and exponential
essentially we have obsolete brains our
brains cannot make sense of this rate of
change so we really need to educate each
other my friend Ray Kurzweil who's a
world-famous futurist and has an amazing
track record at predicting these
exponential changes he uses a famous
example it's really simple but I think
it's important that people take it in in
order to understand what makes this kind
of radical change possible and he says
take 30 steps if you take 30 steps
linearly you go one two three four five
thirty steps later you get to 30 that's
pretty simple that's how our brains make
extrapolations about distance and about
what's coming and about the future now
if you take those same 30 steps but you
take them exponentially you would go to
four eight sixteen thirty steps later
you'd be at a billion that's the
difference between linear growth versus
exponential growth 30 steps 1 2 30 30
steps 1/2 a billion and that accounts
for the reason that the cell phone in
one's pocket today the average
smartphone is a million times cheaper a
million times smaller and a thousand
times more powerful than a supercomputer
that was 60 million bucks half a
building in size 40 years ago so what
used to be half a building now fits in
your pocket so the tools to change the
world are and everybody had everybody's
hands the supercomputers of yesteryear
are in everybody's hands a young person
with a cell phone in Africa today has
better communications technology than
the US president had 25 years ago this
is also out of Peter Diamandis book
abundance so consider what that means so
it used to be half a building now it
fits in your pocket
in 25 years it'll be the size of a blood
cell it'll be reverse engineering us
from inside computers trillions at times
more powerful than the ones we have
today we'll be inside of our bodies you
talk about the coevolution of humans and
technology people think technology is
this separate artificial thing it's in
symbiosis it's a who and what we are
it's a part of who and what we
eventually we're going to closed-loop
because the technology is going to go
inside of us I'm very excited about the
three overlapping revolutions we're
seeing obviously information technology
piggybacking on Moore's law the
computers get faster every two years
twice as powerful half the size etc etc
they're shrinking then we also have bio
technology biotechnology means mastering
the information processes of biology
understanding that our by a lot that our
biology is software and that that
software can be upgraded
just like we upgrade our iOS on our
iPhone we're going to be able to upgrade
our biological software the famed
futurist Juan Enriquez says you know why
this gets really exciting because when
you can master the information processes
of biology you have software that can
write its own hardware computers could
never do that
but biology can we had the world's first
artificial organism created a few years
ago by craig Venter man creates life and
becomes God Alan Harrington wrote a book
called the immortal list where he says
death has become an imposition on the
human race and is no longer acceptable
and any philosophy that accepts death
must itself be considered dead it's
questions meaningless its consolations
worn out perhaps these technologies are
our rehearsal perhaps by reverse
engineering life we have decommissioned
natural selection as Edward o Wilson
says and now we get to look deep within
ourselves and decide what we wish to
become evolution has woken up evolution
has evolved its own evolved ability as
Kevin Kelley said in that video we're on
a trajectory smack in the middle between
the born and the made man is a bridge
and not an end the other revolution
we're seeing is in artificial
intelligence we create non-biological
intelligence sentient that is not
limited by the inherent limitations of
biology digital Minds that can be
endlessly upgraded people worry about it
right I think the Terminator scenario
because they're like oh those things are
going to take over but those things are
us they're us the cognitive philosopher
Andy Clark says we need to get over
our skin bag bias which is this
assumption that's only what what is
within our tissue that is natural and
that what we create is somehow unnatural
but that's not true
technology is an outgrowth of the human
mind technology is imagination made
manifest technology psychedelic the word
psychedelic means mind manifesting
Terence Mckenna says we live inside of
condensations of our imagination and we
really do
somebody dreamed of flight now we fly in
aircrafts all over the world with our
smartphones devices made of plastic and
metal we punch a few buttons and we send
our thoughts through time and space
transcending time space distance we're
gods
another thing that's often talked about
in this next video I'm going to show you
is this idea of mind over matter because
obviously this is used in new-age bumper
stickers Oh mind over matter our
thoughts can change the world but I'm
interested in more concrete examples of
how imagination can transform the world
and I love the writer David Deutsch his
book the beginning of infinity really
turned me on because he's just totally
out there with his examples of mind over
matter so I decided to create a video
that is demonstrative of just how our
thoughts can spill over terraform and
transform the planet and maybe the
universe next video please
I am very much optimistic reminded of
rich Doyle's live Darwin's pharmacy and
he says dreams are not lack reality real
patterns of information work when the
imaginary foundation says that the role
of your imaginations to conceive all
these delightful futures choose the most
amazing exciting and ecstatic
possibility and then pull the present
forward to meet it that is what we do we
bring our imaginings into existence but
I think that as technology has ways to
outsource our mental capacities to our
tools so much more our ability to
manipulate the physical world as
increased in exponential fashion so
we've been able to shrink the lag time
between our imaginings and their
instantiation the real world they even
don't speaks in his new book the
beginning of infinity says look at the
topography of the island of Manhattan
today
that topography the topography in which
the forces of economics and culture
human intent have trumped the forces of
geology I mean the topography of
Manhattan today is no longer shaped by
mere geology it's shaped by human mind
and my economic and my culture so what
David Deutsch extrapolates is that
ultimately that will be the fate of the
whole Europe
he says gravitation and antimatter my
foolish universe and its earliest at
least interesting stages but eventually
the whole entire thing will be subject
to the intent of substrate independent
infinitely more powerful minds and to
conceive of that just it makes me feel
ecstatic that's true you know thank you
thank you I do feel ecstatic when I
contemplate these possibilities just
reveling in those possibilities gets me
off I have a mind gasm literally and I
started to create these videos a part of
me is just because I'm a control freak
right I'm profoundly haunted by the
impermanence of life and by the
impermanence of inspiration inspiration
is a profoundly fleeting and profoundly
lonely experience and I think the goal
of any artist whether it be in paint or
in song or in cinema is an attempt to
put people in one's head to invite us to
smash our sense of separateness and to
say this is how the dots connected
inside of my consciousness I hope that I
can communicate that to you and I hope
that you can understand that I'd like to
share with you a quote by Alain de
Botton one of my favorite philosophers
out of the UK and he says and this has
to do with the power of art to
communicate to make people feel
something as compared to let's say
journalism
so he says the artist is willing to
sacrifice a naive realism in order to
achieve realism of a deeper sort like a
poet who though less factual in a
journalist and describing an event may
nevertheless reveal truths about it that
find no place in the other's literal
grid I'm trying to get into the
implications of what's happening on the
back of these exponential emerging
technologies when we reverse-engineer
life itself when biology becomes the new
canvas for our aesthetic design what new
forms of genius might come out of that
as Kevin Kelly said in my first video
right how impoverished would this world
world world have been were not for the
invention or the technology of the oil
painting allowing van Gogh to unfurl
through it
what new genius will come out with
inventions we cannot even conceive of
yet people worry about disruptive
technologies they worry about their jobs
half the jobs that exist today didn't
exist fifty years ago or a hundred years
ago most of the jobs that are going to
exist 20 years from now don't exist
today
what new forms of artistry what new
forms of human expression what new
occupations and vocations will emerge
out of these tools and our ongoing
coevolution with these tools and what I
love about using cinema to convey these
ideas was probably described best by
George your sorry Jean Youngblood in his
book expanded cinema
he said that cinema like life itself is
a process of becoming a part of man's
ongoing historical drive to manifest his
consciousness outside of his mind in
front of his eyes now something perhaps
a little more practical that we talked
about on the back of these technologies
is the issue of big data and privacy and
companies and corporations and
governments knowing more and more of our
behavior and being able to take
everything we do and turn it into an
algorithm that can maybe predict what
we'll want before we know we want it and
I was quoted yesterday in a panel and
that I think things like targeted
advertisement or just
engineered serendipity it doesn't
actually concern me I'm more about the
idea of radical openness and when I
think of big data I actually get excited
by the new forms of self insight that
might emerge from that I read recently
an article that said that apparently
when forage your ants hunt for food the
patterns of how they do that mirror the
tcp/ip protocols that control
information flow on the Internet what I
went to an exhibit at the MoMA in New
York called talk to me where they showed
me this graphic animation that showed
the world and there was these things
that look like weather patterns flowing
on it and they were like no that's
actually the Diaspora of people leaving
conflict zones it looked like weather
patterns and I think what we're finding
is that the more we can measure in the
Internet of Things walking around with
computers in our pockets that are
measuring what we like what we buy where
we go what we search for etc etc etc
when mapped out when we get the long
view when we get the big picture what
we're seeing is these patterns keep
recurring from the Nano to the Galactic
from the organic to the man-made we're
realizing it's all part of a continuum
and all of it is nature unfolding its
complexity unfolding it's just unfolding
in different scales and in different
realms but we are of nature we feel like
autonomous free agents going around our
lives but then the patterns that work in
the organic world work in the man-made
world you know I heard Stephen Johnson
who wrote his book where good ideas come
from a natural history of innovation he
has a lot of great examples of how he
calls the coral reef the city of the sea
because it turns out that the patterns
of biological innovation in the coral
reef that make it the most biologically
diverse environment in the ocean mirror
the patterns of innovation of cities
which are where the most memes are
created has to do with the diversity and
the collision of ideas and the amount of
idea sex that's happening in cities as
comparable to coral reef so what does
this tell us if we want to innovate more
we need to create these spaces in which
ideas can have sex we need to promote
this free flow of information we need to
promote transparency so that we can gain
more
our self insight into how we work so I
decided to make a video about this this
is my homage to Big Data and I call it
it was inspired by Isaiah Berlin's quote
to understand is to perceive patterns so
let's roll that video
to understand is to perceive pattern of
course what this means is the true
comprehension comes when the dots are
revealed and you get to even join us
Longview and you see the big picture
this is idea of a pattern patterns
patterns recurring patterns across
different scales in reality you know
Paul Stamets talks about the mycelial
archetype and how the information
sharing systems that comprise the
Internet look exactly the computer
models of dark matter in the universe
look exactly like the neurons brain they
all share the same inserts winkle
filamentous structure it's the rise of
networked ISM as big data advocates talk
about how and made systems aren't
looking exactly like natural systems and
what we can measure the more we can
visualize them we can visualize the more
expands our consciousness my CDs
recurring patterns across scales of
reality blows my mind and I think that
technology increasingly is becoming a
spanner of human consciousness extends
our reach and vision and revealing so
much more it's like whereas once I was
blind now I could see Jeffrey West from
the Santa Fe Institute is telling us
that cities are really like organisms
you know alleys are like capillaries how
is it possible that a man-made
artificial technological system is
behaving like a natural system the more
efficient it becomes the board starting
to look like nature really interesting
weird stuff you know but but it makes me
optimistic it's like when Steven Johnson
says look if we can understand all this
stuff we can I mean anything becomes
possible right it's the adjacent
possible standing as a sort of shadow
future a map of all the ways the present
can reinvent itself it's beautiful stuff
it is beautiful stuff thank you so much
guys you know I love I love Steven
Johnson his new book future perfect
talks about pure progressives and the
power of peer networks to solve problems
I think is amazing but that last line
about the adjacent possible I think
that's a great takeaway message for us
to constantly probe our adjacent
possible I mean don't you love that the
idea that we shouldn't look upon the
world as it is we should look upon the
world and see what it could turn into
it's this shadow future we should draw
the maps of all the ways in which the
present can reinvent itself now those
videos when I started doing them they
were a non-commercial experiment I
created a name I created an art form I
called them shots of philosophical
espresso really it was just an excuse to
communicate ideas the way that I enjoyed
communicating them which is like with
this and ecstatic excitement this
attempt to like immortalize and hold in
stasis inspiration itself you know like
I think it's very indicative of this
idea that we should not go quietly into
the night but we should rage rage
against dying of the light if the human
the purpose of the human machine
civilization is to transcend all
previous limits and turn into gods or a
Stuart brand says we are as gods and
might as well get good at it then I was
going to start by not letting those
fleeting exquisite moments of
inspiration go to waste but rather I was
going to immortalize them which is what
I love to do and then share them with
people all around the world and they've
been seen you know over a million movie
talk over a million times now and I
think it's indicative the people are
hungry for this kind of like high-level
discourse but they want it to be
compressed
you know they says this I don't feel
entitled to ask people for their time
because I know that we're saturated in
media and we have what's called
cognitive bandwidth anxiety we just
can't process all the information that's
coming at us so that's really the
inspiration for this but what
fundamentally at the end of the day what
I want to communicate to you guys is a
sense of awe and a sense of wonder when
I my heroes Carl Sagan was exceptionally
good at doing this Timothy Leary Bucky
fuller used to call themselves
performing philosophers they take these
intergalactic sized ideas and they use
the power
Media communication to spread those
ideas to turn them into self-replicating
memes that can go out into the world and
this idea of awe as a kind of reassuring
quality and ability to contemplate our
own existence and marvel at ourselves as
Sophocles says manifold the wonders
nothing towers more wondrous than man
it's about creating narratives that are
positive it's about awakening the minds
attention from the lethargy of custom
and the film of familiarity and
redirecting it instead to the wonders of
existence because there are an unending
amount of wonders and so got really
turned on when I saw this study out of
Stanford that says guess what
blowing our minds on a regular basis is
actually psychologically beneficial
every time we push our perceptual
boundaries beyond their limits we are
reborn and refreshed and reset and it
leaves us with profound benefits so I
thought that's cool because if my videos
are non-commercial shots of espresso to
inspire people with awe and now all is
actually good for us why not make a
video that informs you with a bit of awe
while telling you what aw is and why it
matters so for my last video which is
called the biological advantage of being
awestruck I am hopeful that it gives you
the chills and you'll notice I speak a
lot slower in it because it's a more
contemplative piece and I uh
I hope that it elicits a sense of just
cosmic Wow
watch the next video
eminent psychologist Nicolas Humphrey
has written the biological advantage of
being awestruck how fortuitous he says
for a species to find its own ability to
contemplate to marvel at its own
existence has been evolutionarily
advantageous in other words that has
been biologically selected for because
it informs our life with a sense of
cosmic significance that makes us work
harder to persist and to survive in
other words ah has helped us survive you
know recent study out of Stanford on the
subject of aw kind of validates this
idea they have found that regular
incidences of ah leave residual benefits
upon the individual that persists such
as increased feelings of empathy and
compassion towards others increased
feelings of altruism increased feelings
of general well in the study they
defined all as an experience of such
perceptual expansion such perceptual
vastness you literally have to
great your mental schema just to
accommodate just to take in the scale of
the experience this is amazing we've all
felt this before first time we stared
upon the Grand Canyon or succumb to the
immersive power of an IMAX film but
perhaps the most exquisite account
experience of all was articulated by the
brilliant Ross Anderson when writing
about Hubble Space Telescope pay
attention he says that the Hubble has
given us nothing less than an
ontological awakening forceful reckoning
is allowing us to contemplate space and
time on a scale just shy
he says gazing upon the famous Deep
Field photograph literally allows us to
mainland the whole of time through the
optic nerve to fit something so
impossibly large it's roughly soul
fussing with smoke
incredible he says through the sheer
aesthetic force of its discoveries the
Hubble distills the impossibly complex
abstractions
physics
to these singular expressions color
light
vindicating keith's famous couple beauty
is truth
truth
you do
thank you thank you that's cool you know
just even now like this idea this this
this notion that an instrument of man a
cosmic optic nerve floating in space can
distill the abstractions of astrophysics
into expressions of color and light I
mean I just spoke so vividly to me I'd
like to show you share with you one more
quote about just just think of the
telescope as a metaphor for what
technology does as an instrument of mind
expansion in its time and this is by
Ross Anderson in its time the telescope
has transformed the night sky from a
decorative ceiling a fixed sphere of
glittering stick figure gods into a
universe whose reaches carry the seeds
of this earth and new Earth's still and
I'd like to leave you with one more line
that puts me in total awe it's from a
website called next nature that has been
kind enough to feature my work they say
they say that design this is what's
important for artists really to pay
attention to design is about to undergo
a paradigm shift today design starts at
the level of the atom we are drifting
into the world of the invisible virtual
realities Nano and bio technologies are
increasingly influencing our aesthetics
and providing new construction kits for
our reality and I think the big takeaway
here can be echoed by again the
brilliant Alan Harrington who's out of
print work the immortal list I recommend
everyone gore Vidal call that the
greatest book ever written he says we
must never forget we are cosmic
revolutionaries not Stooges conscripted
to advance a natural order that kills
everyone thank you very much
thank you